Reescribe la siguiente expresión como un producto con exponentes positivos,
posteriormente evalúa la expresión
cuando "x" es igual a 2,
y nos dan "x" a la -3 por 5 a la -2, por "x" cuadrada,
y lo que hay que darse cuenta aquí,
es que si tienes algo
elevado a un exponente negativo,
eso es exactamente igual a 1 sobre
la misma base
elevada a la versión positiva del exponente,
así "x" a la "-a" es igual a 1 sobre "x" a la "a".
Así que aplicando este conocimiento, aquí
tenemos que "x" a la -3
es igual a 1 sobre "x" cúbica
por 5 a la -2 que es igual a 1,
sobre 5 al cuadrado por "x" cuadrada.
¿Y qué tenemos entonces?
En el numerador tenemos 1 por 1, por "x" cuadrada,
así es que esto es igual a "x" cuadrada,
y en el denominador tenemos "x" cúbica por 5 al cuadrado, 5 al cuadrado es igual a 25.
Aquí podemos suponer que esto es implícitamente "x" cuadrada sobre 1,
entonces tenemos 25 por "x" cúbica por 1,
esto es igual a 25 por "x" cúbica,
y aquí podemos simplificar esta expresión,
porque tanto el numerador, como el denominador
son divisibles entre "x" cuadrada,
"x" cuadrada entre "x" cuadrada es igual a 1
y "x" cúbica entre "x" cuadrada,
es simplemente igual a "x",
y aquí podríamos utilizar otras propiedades de los exponentes, pues "x" al cuadrado entre "x" al cubo
es igual a "x" a la 2 menos 3,
esto es igual a "x" a la -1
y "x" a la -1 es igual a 1 entre "x",
así es que aquí tenemos 1 entre "x".
De cualquier manera que la hagas mientras sea una manera válida, vas a obtener el mismo resultado.
Al simplificar obtuvimos entonces 1sobre "25x".
Ahora nos piden evaluar cuando "x" es igual a 2.
Cuando "x" es igual a 2, esto es igual a 2
y aquí tenemos 1 sobre 25 por 2,
que es igual a 1 sobre 50 y hemos concluido.
Reescribimos la expresión con un producto
con exponentes positivos, fue lo que hicimos aquí.
Todos los exponentes son positivos
y le evaluamos para obtener 1 sobre 50.